on metagenomics this introductory
webinar will highlight
applications of metagenomic sequencing
and methods of analysis for metagenomic
data that are used
in various research biomedical and
agricultural
applications before we start speaking
about metagenomics
i wanted to introduce you to omix logic
programs
in africa and more specifically a new
partnership
with helix biogen institute that will
help more students
and researchers gain access to omix
logic training
and research solutions in nigeria
to speak about the significance of data
literacy and bioinformatics in nigeria
i would like to invite dr oladipo elijah
kolapole the founder of
helix
university has a phd in microbiology and
a master's degree in medical
microbiology
and parasitology in the past he has been
a lecturer and research director of
molecular biology
immunology and bioinformatics research
laboratory
and now continues to participate in
biomedic
across nigeria and around the world dr
kolavule over to you
yeah good afternoon everyone uh it's a
nice
privilege given to ross to be here and
to collaborate
with our partners uh pine biotech
t-platformer turbo informatics
alex bargin institute is a
an upcoming institute in nigeria
that is involved in capacity development
in the era of
bioinformatics and we are running a lot
of courses
like a certificate diploma and now we
are having
a collaboration with our partners now in
order to allow
nigerian scientists both young and hold
african scientists both young and hood
to know
much about bioinformatics and how to use
various tools
in order to solve real life problems
and i want to believe that as we are
commencing this program
we know each other better and i wanted
to know that
the facilitators for this program their
hair helped to give you the best
give you what it takes to know much
about bioinformatics
and as i believe that at the end of the
seminar
we all will be interested to move
further to the next stage
into the retraining and thanks everyone
we are welcome
thank you so much so much uh doctor
for organizing this workshop i would now
like to say a few words about the omics
logic team and our collaborators who
have made this training possible
my name is vipsha
my name is beepsha biswas and i am the
omix logic community manager
responsible for daily interaction with
thousands of users
that are part of our bi-informatics
community
managed by pine biotech over the course
of the past
several years our team has been
collaborating
with a number of academic institutions
around the world
that have participated in content
evaluation
curriculum review and project design as
a result the omics logic programs have
been thoroughly evaluated
and are known to lead to excellent
outcomes
the goal of the omits logic programs is
to provide training in bioinformatics
enabling independent research guided by
mentors
and pure example developing a growing
community with
shared passion for data-driven research
and
appreciation of citizen science enabling
students clinicians
and faculty of all backgrounds to
develop novel
and independent research using latest
technology
in life and data sciences
our mix logic metagenomics training
program will be guided by
experienced trainers that have ample
experience with bioinformatics
in both academic and industry
applications
i will now invite elia brodsky who is
the ceo
of pinebiotic to speak about metagenomic
sequencing and the upcoming program
over to you elia
thank you vipsa and thank you everyone
for joining today's webinar
so what we are going to cover in this
webinar
is a little bit of an introduction to
metagenomics
as sequencing and how this data could be
analyzed and used so that in the context
of the upcoming program
you will have a sense of what we will do
together
so let's start from the very beginning
the connection between
disease and microorganisms has been
established
in the 1800s and already towards the end
of the 19th century
laboratory methods for growing
microorganisms in a lab culture were
developed
helping characterize them with staining
these studies provided important
information about bacterial
function in isolation but it was soon
apparent that most microorganisms
actually live
in complex communities and today we know
that the microorganisms or the
microbiota
communities of microorganisms that make
up the human microbiome
are not just unicellular organisms
living alongside each other but instead
they
form highly regulated structurally and
functionally organized communities
that are attached to surfaces as
biofilms
with inter-species collaboration and
antagonisms that contribute to ecologic
stability now many of us are probably
familiar with this stability it's
fascinating
that we know for example trying to
battle with such
common skin conditions as eczema acne
and dry
skin so these communities
are distinct and connected
and they are determined to maintain
their community the way that it is
and bacteria within a biofilm can
communicate with each other by producing
detecting and responding to small
diffusible signal molecules in a process
called
quorum sensing sensing which confirms
benefit for host colonization biofilm
formation
defense against competitors and
adaptation to changes in the environment
quorum sensing activities in biofilms
are also involved in the virulence and
pathogenic potential of bacteria
and are therefore an important factor in
understanding and controlling bacterial
infections as they enable
microorganisms and biofilms to become
more tolerant of host defenses
and antimicrobial agents so
microorganisms
are living in communities forming
specific structures and those structures
help them maintain that community by
leveraging different characteristics of
the bacterial species
found in a given microbiota or community
of
bacteria the human microbiota is
estimated to be
10 to the 13th to 10 to the 14th of
microbial cells so it was previously
thought
that there are many more microorganisms
in the human body
compared to the human cells but today we
know that approximately it's one to one
ratio of microbial cells to human cells
and these numbers are primarily derived
from the total bacterial cells in the
colon
which is the organ that harbors the
densest number of
microbes however each one of these
microorganisms
carries important functional properties
in genes that contain genomic
information
these properties and the genomic
information about microorganisms
have been of a growing interest to the
scientific community and so now
there are over eighty thousand
publications on the microbiome and this
number
is continuously growing showing the
significance of microbiome
in a number of different applications
however the majority of biomedical
studies on the microbiome have up until
now been about the gut microbiota
but we'll see how major projects and
ongoing studies are expanding the role
of microbiome
in a variety of different applications
so since the 1990s microbiome studies
have
significantly advanced our understanding
of different types of microbiota
for example we see here metagenomics of
the human intestinal tract
and the subsequent human microbiome
project these are
huge studies that have been made
possible through the advances in
metagenomic sequencing
as a result we now know that there is a
distinct skin
lung gut and even brain microbiota
that are characterized in the context of
healthy
but also diseased conditions
and so over the past decade more than
1.7 billion
us dollars has been invested in human
microbiome research
major projects are underway in the
united states
the european union china
canada ireland south korea and japan
and this investment has really showed
and confirmed the importance of the
microbiome
to human health and human development
some 20 of us investment in this
research
has gone to two phases of a large
project called the human microbiome
project or hmp
which is creating the research resources
needed to study
the human microbiome both in healthy
development
and in diseases and one of the major
goals of hmp
which was launched in 2007 was to create
a toolbox of reference data sets
computational techniques analytical
methods and clinical protocols so
let's talk a little bit about what is
known about the microbiome
function in for humans for people
so today we know that endogenous human
microbial communities contribute to
a critical metabolic physiological
and immunological function including
differentiation
and maturation of the host mucosa and
its immune system
food digestion and nutrition energy
generation metabolic regulation in
control of fat storage
processing and detoxification of
environmental chemicals
maintenance of skin and mucosa barrier
function
development and regulation of the immune
system
and prevention of invasion and growth of
disease-promoting microorganisms
so to study these functions and how they
vary in different conditions there have
been
a number of technologies that have been
instrumental
to our understanding of how these
communities
live function and develop and respond to
different stresses
so these questions are primarily being
answered by two types of technologies
one is called
sequencing so whole genome sequencing or
whole dna sequencing
or metagenomic sequencing or meta
transcriptomic
sequencing as well as different types of
amplicon sequencing which we'll talk
about in just a
few more slides and mass spectrometry so
mass spectrometry allows us to detect
spectra of proteins and metabolites and
really
understand what type of functional
enzymes
and molecules are being produced by
these microbiota
so here we'll talk about how these
techniques are used
and try to understand one of the major
functions of metagenomic sequencing
which really
allows us to understand the
communities as a functional
group and so we'll talk a little bit
about how
the microbiota could be sequenced
mapped onto a database of reference
genomes of all known bacterial genomes
and give us a sense of species richness
so in this context metagenomics is
really
different from other types of omics data
so typically when you think about omix
data you're thinking about genomics or
transcriptomics and all of these focus
on the whole of a single
organism and organisms
like metagenomics is the community of
microorganisms they live in communities
and so when we think of metagenomic
sequencing we're really trying to
understand
the composition and the structure of
that community
and so this genetic material is sampled
directly from an environment so it skips
that stage of
isolating a particular strain and allows
us to understand how do they
interact with each other in their
natural environment
and so when we think of metagenomics
we can really think of them in two ways
so
the first one could be applied to
environmental culture free sequencing
to study populations and we can also
use sequencing to extract a particular
strain
and understand how it relates to
other types of known genomes that we
have characterized
so these two types are really sometimes
used in a complementary way for example
if we want to look at the gut microbiome
we want to ask the question what types
of bacteria and in what proportions
are they inside this particular
individual and we might want to compare
that individual to another individual
and sometimes we want to understand how
a particular
member of this community behaves and
what's different about it for example a
some kind of a
antibiotic resistant bacteria or
microorganism
and then we can use full genome assembly
and mapping to understand how it could
be
mapped to known species so
the first type which is really 16s
ribosomal rna metagenomic sequencing
is a low-cost and flexible approach
to study how the composition
of a particular microbiota could be
characterized
so this kind of a sequencing allows us
to
essentially extract a 1 500
long base pair um
sequence of the 16s ribosomal rna gene
map it onto a database where we
have organized all of our data into
operational taxonomic units through
pairwise
peer-ended sequencing and by mapping
we are really understanding how
a taxonomy of a particular microbiota
explains a particular microbiota a
particular defined
community so what is the 16
s ribosomal rna gene you have
the bottom ribosomal subunit or the 30s
small subunit of the ribosome that is
specific
to bacteria inside that
you have the 16s ribosomal rna gene so
this is actually
rna and that could be sequenced using
a specific primer so that you're only
sequencing four particular hypervariable
regions now a lot of times
hypervariable regions three and four are
used
and by mapping those onto a known
sequence of 16s ribosomal rna
we have a particular sensitivity
to different levels of taxonomic
classification so we can ask the
question
for example what you see here is based
on phyla of all species that are present
what is the proportion of different
phyla in different places of the body
for example you can see here
skin oral cavity etc and now you can ask
the question
well how can we analyze this data
and what are some of the approaches to
ask specific research questions
of the data that we have generated using
next generation sequencing
so an important part of this is to
really understand
the relationship between different
microbiota
and the relationship between the host
and
whatever that community contains which
could contain
a number of members for example
bacteria and viruses right so those
could be pathogens and they could be
helpful bacteria and so we want to for
example know the composition how much
how many are viruses how many are
bacteria
or what types of viruses are present or
what types of bacteria are present
we might want to understand the
relationship between the host
and the microbiota for example changes
in microbiota
how do they affect the host or if we
have specific clinical or phenotypic
data
for example disease stage and not
disease stage susceptible and not
susceptible
how do we characterize those types of
interactions and changes across
different conditions
so ultimately the role of bioinformatics
and different
aspects of bioinformatics is to help
establish
those relationships and help us identify
specific types of relationships that
could be
applied to the development of biomarkers
and an understanding of specificity
features and result of changes in those
features
as we think about diagnostic and
therapeutic applications so let's take a
look at a few examples and by the way
all of these examples are taken
so that we can understand and anticipate
what kind of
training is going to happen when we turn
to the metagenomic
onyx logic metagenomic program so
what are project examples when we say
project examples
really what we mean is curated data sets
digested publications and guided
tutorials
that we're going to include in the onyx
logic metagenomics training program
so that any one of you without or with
some background in bioinformatics and
in microbiology can understand how this
metagenomic sequencing data could be
analyzed
for some kind of a valuable application
so what are those valuable applications
one example is a project called the
american gut and even though it's called
the american gut this is a part of the
human microbiome project so in fact
international participants have
contributed their samples
to a group that studies those samples
by sequencing them and asking survey
data
to establish some general trends about
the way that the people that are
uh reporting for example sensitivities
or their level of activity
or their background ethnic background
and their
location or maybe specific food diet we
can understand
variation of healthy human microbiome so
one of the examples that we'll do is
we'll take
a number of representatives from the
american
microbiome project and we're going to
prepare a report so this
is what you see right here this is an
actual report from the american gut
that shows how a particular user that
has submitted their
samples what are the most abundant
microbes
most enriched microbes how does your
microbiome
compare to others and maybe some
specific
examples of different groups people that
are more active and less active and so
we'll ask the question what are some
general trends
for microbiome variation in healthy
human population
another important application of
microbiome
is something that is a little bit less
intuitive so we'll take a look at a
project
that tries to separate the influence of
microbiome changes
from the overall environmental
conditions
that have an association with
different types of behavior so we'll
take a look at an animal model study
where animals were fed with a particular
diet a high fat diet versus a normal
diet
and then that microbiome once it has
been established
was transplanted into another set of
animals
and then their behavior was studied and
so
through those kinds of studies we'll see
how you can observe
a relationship between microbiome
composition
presence of particular bacterial phyla
or species
and the composition of it and then you
can identify
potentially an interesting insight into
how
anxiety and behavior could be affected
simply by microbiome another
important application of microbiome that
we'll look at
is the determine the the way that the
microbiome
and the food that the microbiome thrives
on
determines efficacy of treatment
and our response to uh
different types of triggers
psychological triggers behavioral
triggers
etc so we'll see at the way that
these types of data sets could really be
informative
and lead to development of intervention
so we'll in fact look at one example
where
a treatment using microbiome
from fecal samples was approved in china
for alzheimer's disease so really
interesting applications of microbiome
in terms of treatment
but we'll also look at the impact of the
microbiome
on treatment response so how
microbiome composition of individual
patients
can have an effect on their toxicity
and beneficial treatment metabolism so
we'll
look at microbiome as an important layer
in that process of taking a treatment
taking a drug
and essentially what happens how
effective is that treatment
is also determined by the microbiome
which is logical right because we just
saw how the microbiome
is related to the immune system and it
forms a biofilm
essentially on the layers of our body
that are exposed to these treatments
but of course microbiome is not only
useful
in biomedical applications it also has a
huge benefit
for agriculture and so we'll see how
microbial communities from the soil from
the water
uh have a major impact on the
growth and the productivity of
particular
types of crops and
for example we look at microbial
fertilizers
which are an emerging class of organic
fertilizers
and consist of dried microbial biomass
for instance produced
on effluents from the food and beverage
industry
so they have been shown to provide
unique benefits especially
in harsh conditions and at the same time
with minimal
environmental impacts and metagenomic
studies on agricultural applications of
microbiome
are really showing promise in terms of
our understanding of the role of
microbiome
but also our ability to develop novel
applications that are designed to
make the crops more productive and more
resilient
in harsher conditions that are coming as
a result of climate change
so now to explain how all of these
topics are going to be covered in our
upcoming program
i will pass it on to dr mohit mazumdar
who is going to explain
what the program consists of and how to
register
thank you and hello everyone
so let me share my screen
so ilia can you make me co-host i have
another login
doctor mahikamdar
ilia
yes sorry yeah
thanks
okay hello everyone and my name is
mazumdar and i'm one of the global
representatives of pine biotech
and in my current role i'm working with
scientist researchers students to assess
with their big data research so talking
about today's uh
session and this program itself so
omixlogic metagenomics is a specialized
program
that not only takes you through the live
sessions courses
and example projects but also get you to
learn by
applying this knowledge to a real
metagenomics project
so as in our all
as in in all of our omics logic training
programs
we will leverage online interactive
sessions
self-guided study materials and
that are crafted designed for with
practical examples so we'll go through
practical assignments
for an immersive experience that has
proven to be effective for thousands of
students who have already completed our
omics logic
training programs so this
uh online program is basically designed
to be equally rewarding for students
and researchers and specially suited for
project based learning on a flexible
schedule
so this program will cover main aspects
of metagenomic sequencing
analysis of 16s rrna
and other aspects of microbiology
research using bioinformatics
so 16s metagenomics data processing
would
result in a table of annotated 16s rrna
genes and they will be read map counts
so the table includes annotation that
that would have like levels of
kingdom phylum class order family genus
and species and things like that
so we will be covering those at towards
the beginning
where we will be doing the first session
uh covering introduction to metagenomics
on 16 february
and then mapping to different databases
so how we can do the annotation and come
and find those using different databases
that are available
then as elia discussed that we will be
going through the
uh data to pipeline and there we will be
using
other tools such as seek and then
the projects so after going through the
couple
of the introductory session and
understanding how to apply
metagenomic sequencing into uh research
or understanding by project examples we
will be going through
uh the uh gut microbiota biome
project human uh microbiome to
understand the human micro
bio variability and followed by that
we will have another project session on
uh
on the gut mic gut brain access and then
we will be learning about
uh the independent project so the
process
uh and towards the end of this program
participants will be conducting
independent or group
projects analyzing data from public
domain
and learning from high impact biomedical
publications
on uh microbiome
so uh in order to study microbiome
or microbial communities or microbiome
microbiomes we will be learning about a
couple of technologies like we
discussed like we will be learning about
16s and 18s ribosomal rnas
and the way analysis to analyze the
hypervariable regions
that can yield important information
about the microbial
microbiome composition so uh the
sessions will include asynchronous
materials
which which have all the information
like uh
the things that we have discussed they
are well described in the courses
so good understanding of the way data is
being prepared we will understand
through the courses
and the asynchronous projects and how
this data is
helping us allowing us to navigate
research
studies with ease that we will be
learning through
the asynchronous courses and that will
be showcasing you
in a while that uh these introductory
and
uh hands-on courses along with the
educational project that you will have
access to throughout this time so other
than the
online sessions throughout the week we
will be going through
um courses and online
projects
so this will be done via the zoom
session so as this
session is ongoing right now we will
have zoom sessions throughout
uh this entire program starting from 16
february
and the sessions will be held at the
same time 5 p.m to 6 30 p.m
western africa time and uh we will have
a team of supporters to be
able to help you transition this
knowledge from
theoretical knowledge to practical
assignments to applying this uh uh
applying this into a research project so
this entire process will be guided by us
uh uh and also will be help getting help
from our africa
from our nigerian team which we will be
whom we will be introducing in a while
so uh during this uh during the last
program or also this
uh during this program once we
transition so first
the first part would be to learn from
the theoretical aspects and learn about
the basics
and then go through the practical
assignments and go through the data sets
and learn how to apply them and then
during the end of
the program towards the end of the
program we would ask you to submit a
research
proposal so that research proposal that
would have an
unique idea or an idea that you wanted
to work on
and that you have discussed with the
mentor and have
uh and that you are sure about the
analysis process
and identified the data set and also the
pros
the analysis methodology that you will
be taking
so we will be uh peer reviewing that
proposal further
with our experts the whom we have
collaborated in the university
and also tower bioinformatics research
center to
be get to be able to get uh uh
peer-reviewed feedback so that we can
improve our research
and move in the right direction so this
whole week
towards the end will include uh
one-on-one meetings with the mentor to
to work on the proposal and also we'll
have group presentations
where uh where the participants will get
a chat will get a chance
to talk about what they have learned and
what they understand
from the point of from their point of
view about the
research question and the analysis that
they wanted to do
so we have been doing it for a while so
our omics logic
uh metagenomics program has been taken
by hundreds of researchers that includes
researchers who starts from the very
basic without
any background of bioinformatics and
also
uh researchers who come from a
background
though who understands and knows the how
the how to apply these technology
to a research question so there are
different expectations that
we have uh we have seen from different
uh categories of students
who starting who are starting from the
beginning uh students who are doing
their phd
research and would want to do something
that would help them publish
or for faculties who are working on some
research projects
that they want to publish or they want
to apply
for more funding so we have been working
with
these researchers and we have been
helping them through our omics logic
research programs
so some of the examples like uh during
the last program
that resulted in like multiple numerous
independent research project proposals
so the project proposals were then
pre-reviewed as i was telling you
and some of them include the analysis of
microbial
ecology of the international space
station
and then implications of long-term human
missions on moon and moon and mars so
thinking about how metagenomics analysis
and how we
these samples that we're collecting
giving us information
to get a better living or to improve
uh what we the challenges that we are
facing by understanding the environment
around by understanding the microbiota
so i'm really excited to be a part of
this collaborative research program
and meeting you all here today and i'm
looking forward to meeting the
uh to meet the participants who decides
to join the program
and to talk more about uh the program
and the registration part um let me
invite people
to guide you through that process uh but
i'll
i'm i'm here i'm available to you and
you can always reach out to us for any
kind of questions
regarding research or projects that you
have interest in
in this area in this field of
metagenomics
thank you thank you so much
dr mohit
now i would like to draw your attention
to the program
resources for different parts of the
session we will leverage
omics logic resources that you can use
to learn
about metagenomics these will include
asynchronous coursework with theoretical
material
quizzes practical assignments our
cloud-based
analytical server where you can analyze
large metagenomic data and visualize
results
the omits logic code playground where
you can practice coding
in r and python as well as a repository
of
project examples we will start with
introductory course work
in metagenomics where we will
familiarize
ourselves with the world of the
microbiome
the modules will also explain key
terminology
and some of the project data sets we
will use in the analysis
some of the practical analysis
approaches we will cover
in this program includes kind to data to
pipelines and philosophy
throughout the course you will be given
directions to
access the bioinfo platform for
bioinformatics processing
and analysis of metagenomic data
the platform includes demo pipelines
as well as data management and analysis
cloud
infrastructure to run bi-informatics
pipelines
different stages of analysis are
performed
in this different section of this
multi-omics platform
the visual interface of the tbio info
platform will enable users to quickly
build
logical crafts like you are seeing on
the screen of their analysis
and understand each step significant in
running the pipeline
for those interested to implement
the pipeline on their own we will also
offer guidance
and references that can be used to
effectively
install all the required packages for
the pipeline
behind many of the scripts written in
popular coding languages such as
r and python these are also
explained in tutorials you will have
access to on our code omics logic
platform
these include beginner tutorials on data
importing
preparation for analysis and standard
visualization of
process data more specialized packages
with publication ready outputs
will be covered in more advanced lessons
that is why this program is built to
provide
students of all backgrounds with a clear
perspective
on big data analytics machine learning
and artificial intelligence
our omics logic step-by-step process is
enabled by
access to complex tools via a simple
and intuitive analysis
platform at the same time exposing
participants
to analysis logic in the context of real
data sets
as you have seen dr mohit explain
an extrapolation of this logic to a
variety of projects
and data sets with assistance from
mentor
and technical support the first step
therefore is to register yourself
and start updating your profile like you
see the participants
doing here here are
also a few examples from previous
participants
who have taken part in the omics logic
programs
reviewed these programs
and also proposed novel research
projects
we are excited that this event has been
led
and organized by our dedicated team in
nigeria that brings together
experts who have an interest in
data-driven research and have all
recently
completed our specialized training they
are now
certified and ready to assist all of you
in joining the program
getting registered finding all the
necessary resources
and helping you troubleshoot any
technical or conceptual challenges you
come across
we have adequately adeloboy who is our
omits logic project lead and a faculty
at leap city university in nigeria
adidas is the omits logic community
manager for
africa and he is a faculty at the
department of oral diagnostic sciences
at bairo university sani hamsa
is a medical laboratory scientist at the
university
of lagos in nigeria i would now like to
invite adi kundi to say a few words
about the programs that we are running
in nigeria and his experience
adi kune over to you
i'm very excited to be here this evening
um speaking with us
like i'm being introduced i'm a faculty
with leed city university here in
nigeria
and i'm also a mentor and program
director with
criteria i want to appreciate by
find out you know for programs such as
these
and english logic method genomics
training which
has been a big participant across the
globe particularly here in africa
and nigeria in order to um gather
relevant bioinformatics t
cells and that is relevant to meta
dynamics
um you know with particular focus on
hands-on experience
you know that would um to benefit in
laws
and be able to apply this to their own
personal proof
you know i'm glad to see that then the
feedback we've had
you know from previous programs with the
running
including some which are currently
ongoing has always been an exciting
you know it is us in the in the team
here in nigeria
and a lot of joy to see that particular
fans get value for
for the money they pay for such programs
as this
and um you know one of our goal of
course is to see but you can't go from
you know literal new skills after the
time of beginning
trainings like this you know to being
able to
learn relevant keys and applying same
skills
to their own personality okay so with
that condition of course
i have no doubt that for as many
participants who will be joining
this president for this logic and
message
training we equally have enough to
benefit
okay um we at least look at nigeria we
are very interested to provide
all the immediate support and mentorship
as well as support that is necessary for
participants to get the very best
from these and forthcoming metagenomics
and program
and so um i would want to
pass it on to my you know our community
manager here in
nigeria i'm just addicted to equally
hard and one or two
i mean to say one or two things thank
you
hello good evening everybody thank you
for
coming here today my name is adita
abujari i'm a
consultant or pathologist at the
american teaching hospital
in kanoe i'm also a lecturer at bayern
university canada and i'm the community
manager
for ole miss logic nigeria
i'm also from pibal tech usa we are very
glad to have you with us
and we're also very glad to partner this
with dr elijah
this this new metagenomics course
we promise that all your questions
queries
shall be duly answered
and whatever queries or questions you
have you can just send it to african
bow you will get prompt response prompt
registration
and and prompt answers to all your
queries
we thank you and we wish you join us to
make this community more formidable
and to be avant-garde in metal genomics
in
nigeria in africa as a whole
thank you very much i'll pass over now
to bibsa
hello bibsa thank you so much
for sharing
i would now like to invite everyone to
get started by registering yourself on
edut bio info this is the first platform
that we will all utilize for the program
so there is a free registration if you
click on the register button once you
are
edu dot t bio info aditya if you can
kindly share the url
in the chat box and if you are
already logged in i will be showing you
the next steps on how
you can register so please go with me to
edu.tbioinfo
and if you have not yet registered for
the program or joining us for the first
time
we'll have the register button right
here and there will be a pop-up where
you can enter your email id
and set your password and you can log in
to the website thank you so much aditayo
for sharing
so let us go and see how this program
is going to be conducted so
this is what we call the organization
page
for the metagenomics program
in collaboration with helix biogen
institute
in this page i am posting the link
to this page so if you're already logged
in
you'll be able to have an overview of
the page
though you will not be able to access
the full page
here you will find the events the
upcoming events of the program so as dr
mohit has already explained to you we
are starting on the 16th of february
so you have about two weeks to join this
program
now talking about the registration
process this is the direct
link to register for the program if you
are already logged in
to the portal you will be able to access
this direct link
and you can see here the details of the
program
now the cost of the program is 150
dollars
but we are giving a special discount for
our participants who are joining us
and to avail that 50 percent discount
we will be sending everyone an email
with a quote and that will make the 150
200 which will give you a 50 percent
discount
and in case there are students who are
not able to afford the 100
program we also have a scholarship
option which we will again
share via email and let me explain the
scholarship option to you
the way the scholarship works whenever
we have the scholarship option we ask
the students to
go ahead and meet with us along with one
of their references
so if you're applying for the
scholarship program
you will have to mention the name of
three of your references
and to reach out to them so that they
can join us
for a meeting based on that meeting
where we can
talk to your uh reference
as well as you and learn more about
where you're coming from and how much
time you can dedicate to this program
you would be offered that scholarship so
if you are wanting to join this program
and have an interest
in metagenomic research then please
start applying for the program as soon
as you receive that
email from us
and moving on i would now like to open
the chat for any questions that you may
have
and invite you all to join the program
and as i did
note in the chat there are a lot of
participants today
who are also interested in infectious
disease research
so i would also like to draw your
attention
to another program that we are all
having on bioinformatics for infectious
disease research as
part of in collaboration with noguchi
memorial research institute
in ghana so if you are a researcher or
a student interested in infectious
diseases
you can also check out this program
which we are
starting from tomorrow
and i'm posting the link again in the
chat box you will receive all of these
details
and all of you who have shared all of
these details with us
we will reach out to you personally via
email
so please make sure that you have also
added your email ids in the chat box so
that we can reach out to you personally
and now i want to open this for any
questions
that you may have
and as you are asking all of these
questions
i would also want to invite you all to
go ahead and join
our social media groups
okay thank you for uh sharing your
details here
i wanted to mention that one of the
reasons why
beeps asked all of you to complete the
free registration
on the educational portal is so that you
can gain already access to the free
course called
introduction to metagenomics this free
course
is going to introduce you to the basic
concepts
terminology and applications just like
what we did today
in this session but in a more expanded
way
and we hope that by joining that course
you will be able to have
access to our additional free resources
that might be relevant to you
so i would like to make sure that
uh all of you have uh tried that and if
you come across
any issues you're welcome to
email us at uh beeps or marketing at
pineda bio
or africa at pine nut bio specifically
if you are in
nigeria or in africa in general and uh
also
we mentioned these social media groups
and the reason why we ask you to join
the social media groups is because we
see
this program that we're going to be
doing with helix
biogen institute as a one of the steps
in building a community
of those of you that are interested in
bioinformatics to application
in application to biomedical and
agricultural biotechnology
challenges so we hope to stay in touch
with you long term
and really get to know all of you as
well as the institutions that are
represented here
and you know develop a sense
of what are the most practical solutions
and uh training that is needed
for all of you that are participating in
these free webinars
thank you
thank you elia and thank you everyone
for joining us today
we look forward to having you with us in
the upcoming session
please reach out to our team at
marketing at pine dot bio and africa at
find out bio for
any questions related to this upcoming
program
and all of you who have shared your
email ids in the chat box we will be
reaching out to you
and if you have mentioned any specific
interests we will also be
reaching out to you regarding all the
resources that we have
if our to that specific interest so
thank you again today
if you do not have any more questions we
would like to end today's session
okay great i see actually there are some
people here uh
sharing their details from uh naguchi
uh university and university of ghana
so it's great to see those of you
um you probably received emails or you
will receive emails about our upcoming
program
there
yes and all of you in nigeria please
make sure to connect with
our team on the ground in nigeria with
africa at pine.bio
they will be following up with you with
some additional details
about this upcoming program
thank you yes thank you everyone for
joining we look forward
to seeing you in the program itself and
we'll be
emailing you the recorded version of
this
uh of this webinar
okay um just to add one more
clarification
the discount for the program is 50 which
is a 33 percent discount
i'm sorry if i mentioned that as a 50
percent discount i just wanted to put it
out there
so we will be sending you the discount
codes and everything via email that you
will be receiving after the webinar
and also anybody who has mentioned a
specific interest in infectious disease
will also send you the details